shelby steele is a senior fellow at the
hoover institution and the writer of
what killed michael brown shelby steele
joins us tonight miss jill thanks so
much for coming on um
as noted i i think that
the democratic theory about replacing
the electorate is actually wrong i think
they're not getting what they think
they're getting
which is kind of amusing
but the whole notion is offensive to me
shouldn't the
purpose of a government be its only real
purpose is to please and enhance the
lives of the people who live there of
its citizens
indeed indeed uh
it's hard it's you know they they seem
to have no other no more arrows in their
quiver uh yeah and to fight with to
struggle with and and so
they're reduced to sort of scraping
around for these for actually these
tragedies like what happened at buffalo
uh as something that you can
you can turn from from tragedy to power
i think i think it's ultimately
uh probably always very often about
power and
whatever
narrative or scenario
grabs power is is what they do no matter
whether whether it makes logical sense
or not
but it an awfully high cost i mean it it
does feel like the social fabric is
fraying the country's really vulnerable
you can feel it just walking around it's
really obvious and so
into a country like that to throw
something like this and to say see they
hate you so much they'll kill you seems
like a pretty reckless thing to say
uh uh it indeed is
reckless to say um
and
i'm not i'm not altogether sure what
what it is that makes them skip over
reality itself so happy to skip over
reality to these sort of fantasy
charges that they that they make uh
but they they obviously get us nowhere
they're they're uh
they're uh uh
at this point they're
quite they're almost willing to do
anything
they seem to have very few very minimal
scruples about how to move forward in
american life at this point
um
my own little humble opinion is is
i've written a good bit about it
is that one of the great forces of one
of the most powerful forces in american
life today
is white guilt
yeah
and uh guilt persona you know you have
to seem to be going against your own
self-interest to
to gain that expiation that redemption
that white guilt basically seems to to
long for
uh and it seems to me that they're
caught in that and
uh at this point and it it uh
it's taking us nowhere
you can't resolve guilt
no you can't it's except except in
church i mean it does seem like
organized religion is a much healthier
outlet for impulses like that
absolutely uh that's where where the
human condition always goes is is to
religion as we should
yes uh
it it is uh that's one of the reasons
it's there and human beings do that all
over the world
uh but the left in america today is not
doing that they're
they're spitting out another sort of
dream vision dreamscape
uh to uh
sort of rewrite them
part of the problem that i think this
has happened to the left is that they
have no they've become exhausted
their ideas have have gotten we've we've
been driven by those ideas now since at
least the 60s
they fail unrelentingly i mean they fail
with the kind of absolute precision
uh and that that uh
that's where they're at they're
desperate
yeah
and there's a nihilism in the face of
those failures i think it's a really
insightful point shelby steele i
appreciate your coming on very much
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight